[Música]
A falta de una semana para la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones brasileñas Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva visitó el estado
de Minas gerais en Río de Janeiro sus
seguidores organizaron un carnaval para
mostrarle su apoyo mientras mantiene su
ventaja en las encuestas frente a Yair
bolsonaro
Joe biden anunció el sábado su intención
de postularse a la reelección en 2024
pese a no ser un anuncio formal de
candidatura en el seno del partido
demócrata hay preocupación por su salud
analizamos las posibilidades de que
vayden repita como candidato a
presidente de Estados Unidos
continúa su paso por México ahora
degradado ya tormenta tropical la
anteriormente dejó dos fallecidos en el
estado de Nayarit tras tocar Tierra como
huracán de categoría 3
Bienvenidos a este nuevo informativo
dedicado a las principales noticias del
continente americano Soy Rodrigo sedano
y es un gusto acompañarlos abrimos esta
emisión en Brasil en francés 24 seguimos
con nuestro cubrimiento especial de la
campaña para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones A falta de una semana el
candidato de izquierdas Luis Ignacio
lulada Silva estuvo en el estado de
minas gerais acompañado por una multitud
de Seguidores además sus simpatizantes
organizaron el que denominaron como
carnalula en Río de Janeiro las
encuestas siguen dando como ganador con
un pequeño margen Alex sindicalista
sobre el actual presidente Jair
bolsonaro Manuel acano tiene los
detalles
bandera rojas ondean en el estado de
minas gerais y la Euforia marca la
llegada del candidato izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva
a solo una semana de la vuelta
presidencial definitiva el ex presidente
Hace un contundente llamado a los
indecisos
[Música]
quería decirles que deben visitar a
todos los compañeros que saben que no
votaron y pedir un voto para nosotros
pedir un voto para la democracia pedir
un voto contra el fascismo y pedir un
voto para que el pueblo brasileño vuelva
a ser respetado
mientras muchos aún dudan de su voto
otros son sus seguidores hace años ven
en la imagen de Lula la del ex
sindicalista y obrero una nueva
oportunidad para ser representados
Esta foto es de 1984 Tiene 38 años esta
foto Soy yo con Lula representa
Esperanza amor unidad que es lo que
significa Lula para nosotros
necesitamos más amor y menos obvio
en una campaña marcada por las noticias
falsas y los ataques cruzados los
candidatos y sus seguidores hacen hasta
lo imposible para convencer a los
últimos adeptos
más al sur en Río de Janeiro sus
simpatizantes organizaron todo un
carnaval ante la creciente incertidumbre
del resultado final entre bailes música
y comparsas movimientos sociales afines
a Lula celebran su camino hacia el
palacio del plan alto
se prevé unos resultados apretados el 30
de octubre la más reciente encuesta de
datafoya muestra Lula como ganador
llevándose un 49% de los votos frente al
45 de Jair bolsonaro una cifra que
genera dudas ante las cerradas
predicciones de la primera vuelta vamos
ahora hasta Estados Unidos el presidente
Joe biden anunció el sábado su intención
de postularse a la reelección en 2024
una afirmación que no es aún una
confirmación oficial de su candidatura
pese a ellos se ha levantado la polémica
por la edad de vaiden que ya es el
presidente de mayor edad en la historia
estadounidense anteriormente hablamos
con el ex diplomático estadounidense
Lawrence Jay gavinner quien analizaba
shibaiden podría ser una figura de Unión
dentro del partido demócrata de cara
2024 yo creo que va a ser difícil para
unir el partido Cuando llegamos más
cerca de las elecciones en este momento
él tiene quiere decir que va a seguir
como su candidato porque estamos muy
cercanos a nuestras lecciones
congresionales muy importantes y él no
puede causar
caos en el partido Demócrito y también
tiene dos años y más de dos años de su
periodo y el momento que dice que no va
a ser candidato va a disminuir su poder
en la región boliviana de Santa Cruz se
vivió la segunda jornada del paro que
exige un nuevo censo en busca de mayor
financiación y representación política
los manifestantes piden que el censo se
realice en 2023 Mientras que el gobierno
de Luis Arce ofrece hacerlo en 2024
entre medias pedidos de reencauzar los
diálogos y amenazas del oficialismo de
aislar la región si no cesa el paro
indefinido que dejó un fallecido el
sábado la central Obrera boliviana afín
al gobierno anunció movilizaciones
nacionales en contra del paro en Santa
Cruz
y en México el huracán rosling tocó
tierra con categoría 3 en el estado de
Nayarit a su paso dejó inundaciones
desprendimientos de tierra y daños
materiales así como dos fallecidos según
autoridades locales ahora el fenómeno
natural avanza por territorio mexicano
degradado ya atormenta Tropical Alba
Santana tiene los detalles
dos tormentas e inundaciones repentinas
así tocó el suelo en Santa Cruz México
el huracán rosling de categoría 3
comienzos de hasta 195 kilómetros por
hora que pusieron en alerta a la
población
el agua empezó a entrar en nuestra casa
sobre las 5 de la mañana sacamos a los
niños y los pusimos en una pared y sus
pies colgaban justo por encima del agua
y solo esperábamos que el agua no
siguiera subiendo y finalmente se detuvo
pero estuvimos ahí fuera bajo la lluvia
durante unas tres horas
importantes
y es que a pesar de que el Centro
Nacional de Huracanes de Estados Unidos
preveían un rápido debilitamiento del
fenómeno roslyn ha provocado fuertes
daños en la región desde inundaciones en
las casas de los mexicanos hasta
desprendimientos de tierra que han
tapado carreteras y hasta vehículos
tuvimos un huracán hace 15 años y fue
bastante malo pero nunca había visto
esta zona así
con cuatro estados bajo avisos de
seguridad las lluvias podrían alcanzar
hasta 25 centímetros no obstante las
autoridades de la zona aseguraron que
las cientos de personas que han sido
evacuadas podrán volver a sus casas
afortunadamente se reporta saldo blanco
y ya podemos comenzar el regreso de las
personas evacuadas a sus domicilios
ahora los expertos prevén que el
fenómeno natural continuará hacia el
interior del país hasta extinguirse más
al sur del continente en Ecuador el
servicio nacional de gestión de riesgos
declaró la alerta amarilla por la
actividad del volcán cotopaxi en el
centro del país que en los últimos días
ha emitido ceniza ya registrado sismos
se trata de una medida de precaución
según explicaron las autoridades y que
se toma para toda la zona de influencia
que comprende a unos 300.000 habitantes
el volcán cotopaxi acerca de 6000 metros
sobre el nivel del mar despertó en 2015
es considerado como uno de los más
peligrosos del mundo por la frecuencia
de sus erupciones
y como preparación para la Copa Mundial
de la FIFA la selección argentina ha
estrenado una nueva camiseta morada
color que pretende representar la
igualdad de género en Argentina como en
muchos otros países latinoamericanos el
deporte sigue impregnado de machismo y
para muchas mujeres argentinas hacerse
un hueco en el campo es una lucha
constante veamos este informe de nuestro
equipo en Argentina
cuando practican patear un balón
regatean y pasan hasta perfeccionar cada
movimiento estas jóvenes no están
simplemente jugando al fútbol están
luchando contra los estereotipos de
género porque aquí en la villa 31 La
Barriada más antigua de Buenos Aires el
campo de fútbol ha sido durante mucho
tiempo un mundo de hombres cuando era
chiquita o sea los varones no te dejaban
jugar porque los hombres eran muy
machistas y no no dejaban que las
mujeres jugarán el deporte el fútbol
para mí no tiene género ya que todos
somos capaces no pero a veces al decirte
cosas o al no compartir la cancha o
sacarte la pelota no no puede jugar al
fútbol Cómo estás hacer que el fútbol
sea accesible para todos es la misión de
Mónica Santos desde hace 15 años esta
antigua jugadora de fútbol lucha para
que este campo situado en el corazón de
un barrio desfavorecido se utilice para
la práctica de las mujeres dos veces por
semana para ella ocupar este espacio es
un primer paso para abrir ambas puertas
a las mujeres
los cambios empiezan ahí y no a partir
de recuperar una autoestima a partir de
percibir un cuerpo como fuerte en contra
de lo que nos dijeron históricamente No
que no puede ser agresiva que tenés que
hacer sumisa pensar nada más que tu vida
focalizada hacia la maternidad el fútbol
nos ayudó a nosotras un montón a
desarmar esos prejuicios esos argumentos
constanza es la prueba viviente de que
la teoría de Santos funciona tras años
jugando en el campo constanza convirtió
su pasión en un trabajo
y ahora sí ahora con 31 años se gana la
vida como entrenadora de fútbol cambió
un montón de mi vida Me formó como
persona
me guío a romper patrones familiares y
hoy en día me siento libre tomo mis
decisiones propias a través del fútbol
algunas mujeres argentinas han
encontrado su vocación otras han
encontrado una comunidad una forma de
brillar como equipo
hasta aquí este r pase informativo sigan
conectados a France 24
[Música]